it is game two of this double header on
this friday night as we come to you from
oracle park it is the padres and the
giants welcome well the giants got a
nice win a little torturous win in game
one of this doubleheader but a win
indeed and now they're gonna hand the
ball to jeff samarja and i think what
gabe kepler wants is samarja just to
give him some quality innings nelson on
the mound for the padres in game two
it'll be the second time that the nelson
has faced these giants this season
enters his 12th game they're all starts
and having one heck of a season an era
just above two opponents only hitting
166. it's been the year of the slider
last three games he is struck out
11 11 and 10
in those 20 and two-thirds innings pitch
last three 11 hits and only four walks
for lumet thank you
to lead it off
and a swing and a miss goes to the
slider to get him
strikes out for the first out of the
ball game on the hill tonight for the
giants will be the veteran jeff semarjan
his 12th year at the big league level 35
year old six for 235 pounder
making start number three
when you take your bats against him
you're going to see a high 80s fastball
that he sinks he cuts he's got a
curveball slider split change he's got
it all right and here's machado
pop them up
it's going to be yastremski
and
the shark with a one two three first hit
and here's belt
belt goes the other way and he's got a
base hit is he gonna go for two
he is gonna go for two
and he's gonna make it easy so that kind
of stunned everybody in the san diego
dive well it serves manny machado right
well he's playing right field he has no
chance to catch this one so longoria is
going to hit with belt at third
and he has a check swing and knocking it
down is moreland but coming in to score
his belt and the giants are on the board
they'll take it any way they can the o2
pitch is a pop-up
crawford calling for this
that was a big league pop-up six up six
down for the shark here's dubon
swing and a miss goes to the slider to
get him third strikeout for nelson lumet
one down here in the third inning oh
i'll tell you what
it's the lumet slider and devon is gone
five in a row retired by lumet
this one is lined to right myers is
there and he makes the catch middle of
the cap high that ends the top of the
third inning giants have a one-nothing
lead
shark looking into joey bart in the 1-2
pitch here it is
got him first strikeout
change up for the payoff pitch it saved
it for a little two-strike surprise
jason castro
this one is out to center field sending
new bond back still going to be over his
head and off the bottom of the wall
ricochet is pretty nasty as castro will
round second base
nearly get out of here to left center
field for jason castro it's back up the
top of the order and trent grisham
2-2 is lined into right center field a
base hit castro being waved around he
will score and the padres tied the score
one to one a two out rbi single for
trent christian that's big it's one to
one fernando tatis junior up
in the air to left field struck pretty
well back goes dickerson looking up and
it is gone a two-run home run for
fernando tatis jr and the padres take a
3-1 lead
home run number 16 of the year for
tati's this this ball goes almost
halfway up
watch where it lands
that oh my goodness
dickerson at first and here is donovan
solano
swinging a miss on a pitch in the dirt
and he chases and strikes out 4ks for
lumet flores
grounded out to tatisse
in the second
on the ground could be a pair
and
it isn't
and the giants are going to get a run
out of this
is garcia threw it in the dirt
and it's now a 3-2 ball game
he is now calling for a trainer that is
not good and he's going to leave this
game
oh no
tommy pham
got him
and that'll end the inning
and here's joey bart
he hits it high
into left center field
it's fairly deep but not deep enough and
that's going to end the inning
and it's wilmer flores
high drive to left
it
is out of here
and the giants take the lead how about
wilmer flores flores makes him pay the
ultimate price
and the 2-2 pitch
got him
he wants to swing the bet there's no
doubt about it well when you get a guy
to swing at a pitch this far out of the
strike zone i mean you're gonna have a
good night christian represents a
winning run as he stands in
and this one is in the air to right
field it is deep and back goes duggar at
the wall it's a walk-off win for the
padres in san francisco try brushing
with a three-run home run and the padres
walk it off a 6-5 win